you know I honestly think it's awesome
that no one who watches this trailer
actually knows what the movies about
Thank You Steven Soderbergh Thank You
side effects is directed by Steven
Soderbergh and it stars Jude Law Rooney
Mara Catherine zeta-jones and Channing
Tatum this movie tells the tale of a
woman played by Rudy Mara who is very
clinically ill she is depressed just out
of her mind and she is prescribed drugs
by her therapist Jude Law now I don't
want to spoil too many details of this
movie so I'll just say that essentially
what happens is she's given a medication
it has some unexpected side effects that
causes some unexpected problems and it
becomes an extremely intense thriller
that I found to be the best film
released in 2013 so far now Steven
Soderbergh has announced this is going
to be his last feature film he said that
you know you never know if that's
entirely true he could be 70 years old
and go I want to make another one and he
has gone out with a complete bang this
is a very Hitchcockian thriller and it's
extremely well written and very well
acted if you're going to go to this
movie alright just let me explain to you
that this is not some like slam-bang
action every minute movie this is a
thriller in which people talk a lot and
the dialogue is so interesting and well
done and the character has become so
fascinating that the movie itself
becomes fast paced if you're into that
type of thing this isn't the kind of
movie that most people would think of as
a theater experience this is definitely
a film lovers movie and someone who
really appreciates good dialog and
amazing cinematography captured always
so well by Soderbergh this film looks
incredible the use of focus is brilliant
the color scheme is amazing the entire
film looks immaculate and it's written
so well the dialogue for this movie I
keep talking about the script but it's
written by Scott Z burns and this guy
wrote The Bourne Ultimatum this guy
knows what he's doing with the pen and
the reason this film works is because of
those characters they're so interesting
you really want to know what's going on
behind these people's eyes like you like
what is up with this person she's
thinking things I don't know what she's
thinking and that all the performances
in this movie Rooney Mara is very good
she's extremely good actually in this
movie but Jude Law in my opinion was the
best of the whole film his performance
was excellent his character felt
realized I didn't feel like I was
watching Jude Law I felt like I was
truly watching a psychiatrist who was
dealing with a very serious problem and
he
he nailed this role so well and like I
said I don't really want to spoil much
about this movie I don't want to tell
you any more plot points or anything
about it really it's just really intense
and it blew me away there's actually a
scene in this movie where my mouth
stayed drop for a minute do you know how
often that happens like that doesn't
happen the scene was so well told it
happens in the mout in the middle
portion of the movie so look forward to
it but I'm serious my mouth dropped and
it stayed dropped at just the audacity
of the filmmaking and how just in your
face it was how well edited the scene
was how the camera moved how the
performers acted in that scene the music
speaking of the music Thomas Newman's
score is terrific and it really adds a
whole nother layer of depth to this
movie because it kind of reminded me of
the social network score not necessarily
in how it sounds but the way that it
added to the film it just added this
whole nother layer of kind of like a
spiraling depth to the movie like where
you just felt like the movie was sucking
you in this portal through this score it
was really well handled getting really
interesting with my descriptions of that
score but it was good is what I'm saying
side effects is definitely in my opinion
the first great film released so far
this year if you're a fan of great
thrillers or a good medical drama or
just a really well acted film that looks
beautiful definitely check out side
effects I'm gonna miss you so de Burgh
because you know what you're doing
behind the camera and I wish you well in
your life
good job man you went out with a bang
I'm gonna give side effects and a -
simply because for one reason I didn't
really feel that Channing Tatum's
character was developed all that well I
can tell the film wasn't really trying
to tell his story and I wasn't really
trying or making much of an effort to
give that character too much depth so I
understand that was kind of their focus
but I think it may have helped the film
a little bit more if you cared more
about his character if you're a film
lover I really think you'll enjoy this
movie thanks a lot for watching guys and
as always if you liked this review then
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes